named for cartoonist Alison Bechdel the
Bechdel test is a tongue-in-cheek
benchmark for basic female content in
movies a film passes the Bechdel test
when it has Elise two female characters
with names who talked to each other
about something other than a man
whatever which a helmet sounds simple
but the vast majority of Hollywood films
fail this simple test in some pass with
just two lines new to two inches here
are some surprising films that pass the
Bechdel test Tiffani listen music I've
got a really bad feeling about this I
don't want you to go now promise me you
won't oh I have pray for the day when I
love will bring us together oh yeah I
want to congratulate you on getting the
lead role and
I heard that you got a supporting role
in general horror movies have an easier
time passing due to lack of romance but
some action movies pass as well Jenny
it's 5:40 know with join the party have
some champagne you're making you feel
like evany czar Scrooge I think so at
mr. Neher I had to watch over my own
neck your neck precious scrawny little
neck so you got any requests for your
final fight Wow
just what any flight of tenant wants no
maintenance passengers so while the
Bechdel test is not exactly a measure of
quality or even feminist content it is a
simple way to highlight gender
inequality in Hollywood and things are
getting better in Sweden theaters have
started to include the Bechtel test in
their ratings and in 2013 films that
passive Bechtel test made more money
than films that fail but our box-office
receipts really a better metric is there
a better way to measure gender equality
and entertainment what do you think